When most people think of ethics or morals, they
think of rules for distinguishing between right
and wrong, such as the Golden Rule, "Do unto
others as you would have them do unto you";
a code of professional conduct
such as the Hippocratic Oath,
"First of all, do no harm"; a religious creed like
the Ten Commandments, "Thou Shalt not kill...";
or, a wise aphorisms like the sayings of
Confucius. This is the most common way of defining
"ethics", norms for conduct that distinguish
between acceptable and unacceptable behavior.
Most people learn ethical norms at home, at
school, in church, or in other social settings.
Although most people acquire their sense of right
and wrong during childhood, moral development
occurs throughout life as human beings pass
through different stages of growth as they mature.
Ethical norms are so ubiquitous that one might
be tempted to regard them as simple commonsense.
On the other hand, if morality
were nothing more than commonsense,
then why are there so many ethical
disputes and issues in our society?
One plausible explanation of these
disagreements is that all people
recognize some common ethical
norms but interpret, apply,
and balance them in different ways in light
of their own values and life experiences.
For example, two people could agree that murder is
wrong but disagree about the morality of abortion
because they have different understandings
of what it means to be a human being.
Most societies also have legal rules that
govern behavior, but ethical norms tend to
be broader and more informal than laws. Although
most societies use laws to enforce widely accepted
moral standards, ethics and law are not the
same. An action may be legal but unethical
or illegal but ethical. We can also use
ethical concepts and principles to criticize,
evaluate, propose, or interpret laws. Indeed,
in the last century, many social reformers have
urged citizens to disobey laws they regarded
as immoral or unjust laws. Peaceful civil
disobedience is an ethical way of protesting
laws or expressing political viewpoints.
Many different disciplines, institutions, and
professions have standards for behavior that
suit their particular aims and goals. These
standards also help members of the discipline
to coordinate their actions or activities and to
establish the public's trust of the discipline.
For instance, ethical standards govern
conduct in medicine, law, engineering,
and business. Ethical norms also serve
the aims or goals of research and apply
to people who conduct scientific research
or other scholarly or creative activities.
There are several reasons why it is important
to adhere to ethical norms in research. First,
norms promote the aims of research, such as
knowledge, truth, and avoidance of error.
For example, prohibitions against fabricating,
falsifying, or misrepresenting research
data promote the truth and minimize error.
Second, since research often involves a great
deal of cooperation and coordination among many
different people in different disciplines and
institutions, ethical standards promote the
values that are essential to collaborative
work, such as trust, accountability,
mutual respect, and fairness. For
example, many ethical norms in research,
such as guidelines for authorship, copyright
and patenting policies, data sharing policies,
and confidentiality rules in peer review,
are designed to protect intellectual property
interests while encouraging collaboration.
Most researchers want to receive credit for
their contributions and do not want to have
their ideas stolen or disclosed prematurely.
Third, many of the ethical norms help to ensure
that researchers can be held accountable to the
public. For instance, federal policies on
research misconduct, conflicts of interest,
the human subjects protections, and animal
care and use are necessary in order to make
sure that researchers who are funded by public
money can be held accountable to the public.
Fourth, ethical norms in research also help to
build public support for research. People are
more likely to fund a research project if they
can trust the quality and integrity of research.
Finally, many of the norms of research
promote a variety of other important
moral and social values, such as social
responsibility, human rights, animal welfare,
compliance with the law, and public
health and safety. Ethical lapses in
research can significantly harm human and animal
subjects, students, and the public. For example,
a researcher who fabricates data in a
clinical trial may harm or even kill patients.
A researcher who fails to abide by regulations
and guidelines relating to radiation or biological
safety may jeopardize his health and safety or
the health and safety of staff and students.
Given the importance of ethics
for the conduct of research,
it should come as no surprise that many different
professional associations, government agencies,
and universities have adopted specific codes,
rules, and policies relating to research ethics.
These include the Nuremberg Code and the World
Medical Association's Declaration of Helsinki.
In summary, although codes, policies, and
principals are very important and useful,
like any set of rules, they
do not cover every situation,
they often conflict, and they
require considerable interpretation.
It is therefore important for researchers
to learn how to interpret, assess, and apply
various research rules and how to make decisions
and to act ethically in various situations.